uh okay
it's a great pleasure and uh and great
una to participate in the alforce
colloquium
and as Peter isinski said last time so
me too I spent most of my nights in
graduate school a reading the papers of
force and birth
um but we didn't have copy machines at
that time
so thank you very much for the
invitation and special thanks to our
host thanks here
um so um
I'll talk about
um so uh joint project with a
symbioplime
and we started quadratic domains
quadrature domains play uh
some role in various areas of
mathematics in particular initial flow
logarithmic potential Theory with
external field more recently including
gas models and we used
um
the Dynamics of the Schwartz reflection
to prove something about
so quadratic domains and then we
realized that
these dynamics of the of the Schwartz
reflection is an interesting object in
itself
besides it's very
alforce burst type of mathematics so
that's why I'll be talking about this
so let me start with uh
uh with the uh
explaining what quadrature domains are
and in particular we'll start with what
which identities
uh unit disk so D is The annotation for
the unit disk it's a quadrature domain
because there's a mean value property if
you want to compute the uh if you have
an analytic function in the unit disk
want to compute the uh the integral area
integral of this function all you need
to do is to take the value of this
function at zero
the second example of the quadrature
domain is a cardioid it's given by the
equation
uh
um
so the definition is is given here and
to compute the array integral over the
cardioid you need to know the value of
the function
and the derivative of the function at
zero
well okay thank you
um okay so here's the definition of the
uh of Schwartz function of equation
domain so
suppose we have a domain u in the uh rim
on the Riemann sphere so C hat is a
complex plane plus infinity
but we assume that Infinity is not on
the boundary the domain can be bounded
in the well complex plane or unbounded
uh
so it is this domain is called The
quadrache Domain if there is exists a
continuous function the Schwartz
function is in the closure of the domain
uh which is a halamorphic
in uh
you in the domain U and on the boundary
the function is equal to z bar
so I said holomorphic in the sense of
the mapping to the Riemann sphere so you
can use the term metamorphic
and the last line on this slide is the
explanation that if you have a Schwartz
function then by residue theorem you
have a quadrature identities
uh so what is this what's reflection uh
will Define what's reflection as uh the
complex conjugates of the Schwarz
function
so usually the turn towards uh
reflection is used locally for a local
reflection if you have a a real analytic
curve then locally you have a reflection
in this curve so it's an
anti-halomorphic involution which is
which fixes the points on the curve but
now we are in a global situation so the
by definition of the Schwartz function
so we have
its complex conjugate is an entire
columnific map which is constant which
is an identity on the boundary
it helps to know that a boundary of a
quadrature domain is a a real algebraic
curve up to a finite set of points and
the possible Singularity where the curve
is not real analytic are only of two
types and there are only
finitely many of those
singular points so the singular points
can be cusps or
double points and the picture
illustrates the uh so what gasp means so
cusp means precisely
okay so uh
this is a magnified view of the boundary
at this point so you have uh you see two
cusps and uh one double points and uh
quadrache domains may only have these
types of singularities
uh and now the main message
is that
um uh Schwartz reflection I use the uh
well letter Sigma for Schwartz
reflection so Sigma the Schwarz
reflection is a uh well it's a hybrid
so it's a reflection near the boundary
of the domain and it behaves like a
rational function away from the boundary
so it's a hybrid hybrid is uh you know
it's uh like Cabernet Sauvignon which is
a hybrid of Cabernet and Sauvignon so
um
the very uh assumable the easiest case
to understand quadrache domain is the
case of Simply Connected domains then we
have a Riemann map and uh
Simply Connected domain is a quadrature
domain if uh and only if the Riemann map
is a rational function
so
um so cardioid is precisely
the image of the unit disk and uh so
this polynomial quadratic polynomial and
uh also let me introduce an unbounded
quadratic domain uh so U is the image of
the exterior unit disk uh so use Capital
Delta for the exterior unit disk
on the Riemann sphere and F is a is a
rational function of degree three
and below is the picture of the deltoid
so this will be the main Heroes of the
talk so the cardioid appears as a
prominent feature in the Mandel broad
set whereas or the deltoid
plays a similar role in the Mandel bar
set so the locus of instability
structural instability of the dynamic z
bar squared plus c
uh well also we can extend the
definition of a Schwartz function by
considering these joint unions of
quadrature domains
uh so for example in the first picture
so you have three circles so the
exterior Circle and then two little
circles they're all disjoint and then
the Shaded area is what we call the
droplets or the name is referenced to
the cooldown gas models I will not be
talking about this
but this picture with the circle
suggests that truth reflection would
give you a reflection group and the
second picture is uh we take
the exterior circle and a cardioid
right and the droplets is shown here so
we can reflect in the circle and reflect
in the cardioid and see what happens
ah finally let me mention that
there's a
uh
that this or
uh well
such thing as or healing show flow
and
under Hillshire floor not only
quadrature domains uh remain quadrature
domains but also we have preservation of
quadricia identities
so flow if you well if you are in
analysis you know what it is so it's the
boundary of domain moves with velocity
proportional to the gradient of the
green function and
hydrodynamically so this is so the
interface between
two fluids of different viscosity and
if you don't know any of this so in
Geometry so think of like Rich flow but
it's a different from breach of law but
still so the formation of singularities
is the main part of the of the story so
I'm mentioning this only uh uh for the
following reasons so
so the
um
if you apply a hillish of law so you
still get a quadrature domains what's
function but you can destroy these
singularities instantaneously and that's
what uh
important also if you look at the bottom
picture so uh here you have the union of
quadrature domains so if you again apply
the hillisho flow then you obtain a
quadrature domain of high connectivity
so then the oldest tangent points
disappear you get unbounded wattage
domain so that's what I wanted to say
okay so now I'll turn to uh example so
I'll have three examples to discuss this
or uh the uh the Dynamics of the
Schwartz reflection and the first is or
the case of deltoid so and uh so that's
the once once again the definition of
the deltoid
and
and then it will be considering uh uh
the reflection in the deltoid so the
Schwartz reflection Sigma and
um
uh well and it's not difficult to work
with the uh
Sigma because or so we have conformal
explicit conformal map and then so you
can express uh this or reflection in
terms of the conformal map so in
particular at Infinity uh
uh so the quadrature domain so this is
the where the Schwartz reflection is
defined is the complement of the deltoid
the deltoid is the droplet but the
Schultz reflection is in u u is the
unbounded domain uh here
so at Infinity it shows the reflection
has a super attracting fixed point
a critical point zebra squared so it
behaves like Z by squared over to a near
Infinity
this is seen from conformal map
representation and uh also uh
uh Sigma has no finite critical points
in you again this scene from the form of
the conformal map
so now the uh here's the claim uh that
if we consider
uh okay so ah the green uh
curve is the boundary of the deltoid
then uh when we apply take the
pre-images of the dualtoid under the
reflection so we get three red uh
triangles
so I said if we consider the schwitz
reflection outside of this hexagon right
hexagon so that's the
claim so if we consider the
sigma restricted to the primage of uh so
then this extends to a map
to cover of the Riemann sphere which is
topological equivalent to the polynomial
z bar squared I will use the term
polynomial for polynomial with complex
conjugates so Z by squared is a
polynomial for me
uh so to to see this or uh uh will
outside of the uh uh curve so we have a
two cover and then uh inside so you this
three uh uh red triangles are mapped
onto the deltoids so that's a three
color so you need to uh cut out this a
budget where you have a three cover and
glue to cover right if you can see the
hexagon the boundary of this region uh
is mapped as a two cover onto the
boundary of the deltoid so you perform
this simple uh surgery and obtain uh
topological uh topological polynomial
it's much uh more difficult to to show
that uh so this topological polynomial
is equivalent to a polynomial and I
really don't know how to do this well in
in a direct way of course if you run a
helicoplow a little bit so then you
eliminate 8 cusps therefore you get some
room in taking the pre-image between the
deltoid and its pre-image so you are in
a duadi harbor situation and polynomial
like maps and then you can do quite a
conformal surgery in this case you have
to go travel as some people call it
trans quasi conformal but again I don't
know how to do this directly so the
result will follow from conformal
removability of of uh
the scene well the the the the the set
that I'll Define right away so we'll
continue uh
um okay so we'll cons uh
uh so that's the first step of the
construction so we reflected uh consider
the primages of the deltoid and now we
take the pre-images of these pre-images
and so on and uh and we call this pretty
images tiles and uh the important thing
is that there is no ramification of the
tiles because the only critical point of
the of the uh of the Schwartz reflection
is at Infinity so as long as we are in
the finite plane so we get tiles
so no ramification of tiles and then uh
so that's the notation so it's
convenient to exclude cusps from the
tiles
so will from the dill to it so I'll call
it k0 then the pre-images
of of this will be called tiles and they
don't ramify as I explained and then the
Thailand said will be the union of all
pre-images and the residual set is the
complement of this and this is where all
iterates of the Schwarz function uh
reflection are defined and in particular
we'll do anything
yeah apologize for this uh and then in
particular the Basin of attraction to
Infinity will uh the points there so
where they will go to Infinity rather
than they land on a uh uh on the deltoid
so it's in the residual set so we have
two open sets the tiling sets and the uh
uh Basin of attraction to infinity and
also we have a singular Set uh the uh
the closure of the primages of all cusps
so that's the the picture so you'll see
the tiling then you see this uh uh
yellow curve which is the closure of all
pre-images of the all cusps and uh the
exterior of this consists of the Basin
so that will be the Basin of attraction
to Infinity
uh and so uh the theorem here is uh that
uh the tiling set the Basin of
attraction to infinity and this closure
of the cusps so they are all disjoint
the the uh present uh the composition of
the sphere and the gamma is this yellow
curve is a Jordan curve and this gum is
conformally removable and and in fact
the tiling region is a June domain so
I'll tell you what a conformal
removabilities so it's when you have if
you have a homeomorphism of the sphere
which is conformal uh
everywhere except on this set then it
extends to a conformal to a mobile snap
with a complex conjugation maybe and
um uh so Jung domain means half so half
of quasi these conditions and
um and then Peter Jones can recognize
his own theorem actually here so all I
need to say is that the Dynamics near
the cusps is very much is pretty similar
to parabolic Dynamics and that was uh
well Peter with Leonard Collison and
yoga so serum so that you have John
domains and and this is basically the
same
uh situation here
um okay so now I want to introduce a
group structure in the uh
tiling sets so it's pretty clear so we
can
uh well let's just uh see that the
picture is completely uh
isomorphic to uh to
um
the modular reflection group
uh so what's a modular reflection group
uh uh I'm not sure if I use the right
terms so but that's what so we have we
have three uh through tangent circles so
a left picture uh and uh then uh it's
precisely the situation that we have so
this uh the circles are quadrature
domains the complement is the droplets
so we consider the reflection and then
we obtain uh and then wrapped in the
limit set of this reflection group so
but we take only one half of this group
so it's the the group is function and so
on the this red circle
then we have this or
a circular triangle uh we'll call it pi
and then uh the rest is the reflection
and and I call this the the the modular
reflection group group
generated by reflex in the three circles
and we consider this as a group as a
group of atomorphisms uh in the in the
disk rather than in the plane
and I will use also the uh uh
what I call reflection map
Associated to this uh
not only group but actually to to the
fundamental uh region pie so it's a map
defined in the complement of this of
this fundamental domain so it's simply
the reflection in the chorus so it's a
piecewise map so in each the complement
consists of three parts and in each part
we take the reflection in the
corresponding Circle so I'll call this
the
reflection map
and then if we take a a map from the
circular triangle onto deltoid and use
Schwarz reflection principle then you
will see that this conformal map will
extend to a conformal map from the unit
disk onto the tiling region
and it will conjugate the uh the the
reflection map of the modular group with
the deltoid group
so group generated by reflections
okay and now I want to compute the uh
the so-called welding map of the of the
welding map of the
uh uh
of the singular uh curve of this yellow
curve so what's a welding map
so if you have a Jordan domain so then
you can map the unit disk onto the in
bounded uh domain
and then the exterior of the unit disk
onto the exterior
domain and then uh but on the boundaries
so we get a map from the circle to gamma
and also from the circle to gamma and
then the we so we have a homeomorphism
of the circle the homomorphism alpha so
this is called the welding homomorphism
so the interior is the uh when we map it
to the disk so then we'll get the uh the
action of this reflection group
so we or rather we have the reflection
map and I'll write this from Lambda to
Lambda so this map goes from the limit
set of the uh this client group
reflection group to the uh it's the
circle but in our in this particular
case it's uh
so it's the it should be the limit set
in this particular case it's the circle
and there are uh the world in Homer
conjugates this to uh the uh map z bar
squared defined on the circle which we
think of as a joule asset which is the
Dual asset of the polynomial
and uh then both maps are two Carvers
reversing orientation so we have three
fixed Point boost cases and uh these
fixed points determined Mark of
partitions so we have a topological uh
Markov chains so with this Matrix so we
just match the itiners with respect to
this Mark of partition and that gives us
the the the the this Alpha so this
homomorphism Alpha is known as the
minkowski question mark function so it's
available
important objects in number Theory and
uh so it it Maps the far a
fractions to diadic uh so what's for a
fraction so you
on the unit interval so that would be
you start with the end point zero over
one and one over one and the Middle
Point you add the numerators and
denominators you get one half but then
the next points would be you add uh okay
so one third so it's the middle point in
this uh geometry so uh middle point
between zero and one half you add the
numerators and denominators and that's
precisely so the uh so if you consider
the
tangent so these four circles so that's
the the point and you map this to the
added numbers
because that's what you get uh uh so
under the dynamic z bus squared of the
circle and on the modular group you get
of a reflection so this is called
minkowski question mark function and so
let me summarize this discussion so I'm
saying that the sigma the the Schwartz
reflection is a hybrid of uh of the
reflection of the reflection uh
map and the polynomial Pi
in the following sense so we consider
the uh
manifold which so we take the closed
unit disk and the closed exterior unit
disk and we identify this boundary using
this minkowski question mark function
then you would get a topological sphere
and we claim that there exists a unique
and formal structure consistent with the
uh so with the charts given by so a unit
disk open unit disk and exterior disk
and then we uniformize and then uh so
unidis becomes the talent domain the
exterior disk will become the uh
Basin of in attraction to Infinity
of the Schwartz reflection and the limit
set of the group which is identified now
with the Jeweler set of the polynomial
will map to the singular set gamma a
yellow curve and the fundamental domain
triangle Pi will map onto the droplet
key onto deltoid and the Dynamics given
by
this reflection
map and the polynomial when you glue
them together they after uniformisation
they will produce precisely the the
Schwartz reflection
so that's what I mean by
hybrid
okay so second example uh
so we'll consider so the theory that I
describe or example that I described so
that's a general
generalizes uh without any changes to
the class of asteroids
so asteroids are uh quadricia domain
which uh which
are given as or the image of the
exterior unit disk and a univalent map
of the form uh
so the form it's
well like polynomial but so the last
coefficient is 1 over n
and if you take the derivative so the
derivative will have
will have a
uh
uh so the coefficient the last
coefficient of modulus one and if f is
univalent it means that all Roots
will be on the unit circle so the image
Curve will will have n plus one cusps
and uh if there are no double points
then the curve is called as an asteroid
so this is an example of an asteroid and
then you use uh
well corresponding function group
reflection group and
you get the generalized minkowski
question mark function and everything uh
works the same the only difference is of
course the groups now come with the
module or with moduli
so the simplest example so that's the
old
asteroids
with four cusps
and the parameter space is the interval
from to third to
minus two third to Third and uh these
are known as Talbots curves
uh so don't pay attention to the ellipse
here but uh so this is the asteroid and
at the extreme point we get uh as well
the singular Talbot curve so an asteroid
or the limit of this asteroid with uh
with the double point
um and I want to so this is the example
that I want to study so I want to say
that uh we cannot use a function model
anymore
and we'll go quite the function and then
in the limit so
get accidental parabolic and at the same
time we'll get polynomials uh not z bar
squared not from the main deltoid well
well but more General polynomial
so so that's the critical uh Talbots and
again you can figure out uh what kind of
uh soil well
objects you uh
um uh you want to to weld uh to so what
kind of polynomial you want to wilt to
uh to what kind of group so this simple
picture so you reflect in the deltoid so
in the in the Talbot critical Talbot
curves and uh well that's the first
pre-images but what you see is that uh
you have three triangles that uh map
onto
uh one half of the uh of the droplet and
uh then you do the C and well and also
three triangles that map onto the second
half and then again uh morally thinking
of this trans quasi conformal surgery
you obtain uh well the topological uh
polynomial with then two critical finite
critical points as well as a critical
point at Infinity
uh and uh
so that's the statement so the pre-image
so the this part of uh the reflection
extends to a map uh uh to a three cover
of the uh Riemann sphere which is
topologically equivalent uh now the
polynomial there's only one polynomial
that well up to uh conjugation
that has uh two critical fixed points
and this was discovered by uh sarasol
uh so you can check that this polynomial
so uh
this polynomial is remarkable that it
has uh
seven fixed points you can see this from
the picture so the uh the
uh
uh the four cusps so the fixed points in
the reflection of then the double point
that gives the fifth fixed point and
then the uh two critical fig uh super
attracting fixed points that we created
uh by the surgery and uh all together we
get uh seven fixed points for a cubic
polynomial in a complete contradiction
to the main uh ethereum of algebra right
but we are considering polynomials with
a complex conjugation and uh there are
it cannot be more than seven
so it's a theorem of uh having some
ciatek
and uh simply by Fatu count you bound
the number of attracting points and then
combine this with Lefferts fixed Point
serum so you get seven and sarasan
discovered this polynomial to show that
you can reach this Bond and there was a
conjecture
conjunction that uh that uh for any and
there is a polynomial uh with uh n minus
one super attracting finite fixed points
so that was proved by year who derived
this from uh just reconstruct a
topological polynomial use substance
Theory uh
theorems that there are no wool that
there are no obstructing
multi-cures so and and that's why and
therefore topological polynomial will
produce uh polynomial with this
properties
so our approach is very different so we
uh so we construct uh
this uh extreme Illustrated and then
perform the surgery
so
the existence so uh
so instead of uh substance Theory so we
use
Korean Newman theorem about the
existence all you need to do so you're
embed embed
embed uh
asteroids into the space of
univalent functions and this is again a
Subspace of a linear space of analytic
functions and it's a compact set if you
fix the the
degree of the polynomial and the
extremal points will be precisely
these polynomials and this works for
rational functional show example how to
so what it looks so what
functions
okay so but now the picture is the same
so you get the composition of the plane
so into
the tiling region and uh
the singular the singular set gamma the
closure of
cusps and double points and the Basin of
attraction to infinity and this picture
the right bottom picture is the Jeweler
set of the sarasone polynomial
uh and uh uh well and now okay so that's
one part so we change the polynomial
compared to our discussion of the
deltoid now we'll change the group so uh
of course or even in the case of the
deltoid
we could change the polynomials we can
take any polynomial in the uh such that
the Jeweler set is a Jordan curve and on
the other hand take any quasi-function
group because we take on the one half of
of the uh regular set of the group and
one half of the
of the for two set of the polynomial and
glue them together so uh and then when
you go acquisite function so then you
can reach the well so that's the group
that will be
a welding
to the saracen polynomial so the
explanatory right so you have four
circles but now you have a tangent
points and then uh the white
curve here is the is the Julius is the
limit set and
um but now we have only one invariant
components so the outside
region and but we can still Define the
reflection map
which is a three cover on primance of
this invariant component and uh
well and then uh
the
reflection map is a cross between uh
between uh the reflection map in the
clientian group and the polynomial in
its Basin of attraction to Infinity so
more precisely so there's a homomorphism
from the Jewelers from the limit set of
the group to the Julia set of the
polynomial which conjugates the
reflection map and the polynomial and
then uh you have you can introduce a
conformal structure in this Union and so
and the situation is the same as in the
deltoid so that's the illustration so
for uh
the topics so top picture is the
uh the case of the Schwartz reflection
so you consider the outside of the
Jeweler set and the inside of the limit
set of the group so you
put them together and the welding is
again the the minkowski question mark
function so only you apply this question
mark function to external angles
okay so that's and uh okay you can uh
consider other examples as well you can
the droplet now is a deltoid minus a
disk
right so that's the union of two
quadrature domains the disk and the
exterior of the deltoid and you reflect
and that's what you get and this is the
uh
all right so the deltoid is minus uh
the key is the droplet is the Dil To it
minus the open disk and the reflection
is a cross of the rational function
so of ah degree 3 in its Basin of
attraction to infinity and the
reflection map of apollonian gasket uh
okay so that's the
um uh the Julia set of the rational
function and this is the
limit set of the
reflection group so that's called a
balloon gasket
and uh R is uh
is uh rational function that fixes four
critical points and uh and those are
very you can't have so you fixes all
critical points it's a degree three
rational functions so there are three D
minus two critical points four critical
points and it fixes them all so that's
the analog of the uh of the
cruelinal but only foreign so this is
better than thurston's theorem because
resourcing theorem uh okay so the
rational case is uh
well several levels more difficult than
the limit Set uh the polynomials here so
where you have
effect oh okay
uh okay so now the last
example is uh well the circle and the
cardioid and um
uh so I repeat repeat the slides so
we're considering the
Union of this joint quadratic domains
the cardioid and the exterior of the
disc
and uh
um
well and um
so let's take the disk to a center to
add this zero uh so let me first say
well just uh
few words about the reflection and the
cardioid so we have a circle
uh the out the exterior disk so we
reflect in the circle there and then we
have a cardioid inside the the disk and
we reflect in the cardioid it's very so
we know very well so what reflection is
the circle uh uh looks like but the
reflection on the cardioids so that's
what uh we you need to use kind of
formal map and it's only quadratic
polynomial so it's pretty easy so you
have to solve only Square quadratic
equations
uh and um
so the I use I fixed the cardio please
so uh which is the image of the
polynomial W over 2 minus W squared over
4S so that gives the cardioid uh
precisely as in the mandelbrot Set uh so
then the reflection uh uh at Infinity
behaves like a constant of Z squared so
zero is the only critical point and at
this point the critical value is
infinity and uh so the uh if you
if you only consider the dynamical
system reflection in the cardioid so you
end up with uh so the tile is the
exterior of the the complement of the
cardioid so it's ramified the style is
ramified already and we're trying to
find group structures in the
non-ramified situation ramified case is
very interesting so you would expect
elliptic elements but it's not what
um uh well I'm talking today so
um
uh so if you consider the pre-images of
the cardioid so that will get cardioids
of of of a size given here
um
so that's all you need to know about uh
the reflection and the cardioid uh so
that's the picture so uh we choose the
case when the uh the disk is centered at
the critical
uh point of the reflection in the
cardioid so the if we choose the center
here so then the orbit of the critical
point will be so zero will go to
infinity and uh the cardioid reflection
and then Infinity will go back to zero
reflecting in the circle
right so we obtain uh well we get a
critically a finite situation
so which means that tiles will not uh uh
be ramified
okay so let's draw the first uh tile so
what we see here uh is this again the
deltoid structure except that we have
these deltoids uh
well with common uh cusps
so we continue and you end up with this
ugly slug in this picture so uh that's
the
okay so uh
the disk minus cardioid is the uh is the
droplets the first tile then you see the
pre images and uh uh and this is all
colored in blue so by mistake so this
should be a different color so that's
the residual set
and uh as I said we have the Dual to a
structure so again by surgery we can
transform uh
uh
so this or a three cover and two cover
with the critical point and uh this will
be a fixed critical point so that's what
we think of as Infinity so to then we
get a rational function of degree two
with the fixed critical point is a
polynomial so uh some way in this uh uh
in this uh droplet you see you have a
infinitive so the infinity in the sense
that you have a polynomial so when you
send it to Infinity
uh well okay so if you send it to
Infinity so this slide becomes a
beautiful butterfly right so you now
you're inverting the circle
and uh well in the polynomial is of
course z squared minus one so this bus
should be Basilica uh uh curve and
um
ah
and so the reflection so the conclusion
is the following so I'm describing the
third situation every time so the
meaning of the hybrid or is is different
so a sigma is a cross between uh the
reflection map in the uh modular
reflection group and uh so with the with
the polynomial z bar squared minus one
and uh the welding is given Again by the
question mark function so what you need
to do you need to consider the circle
lamination
given by external angles uh so on this
Basilica so I call it Lambda you take
the primage of the lamination and the
the minkowski function and then uh then
consider the factor map and that this is
how you glue together the uh exterior of
the
of the
sorry the field in Julia set of this
polynomial with the uh uh so with the
reflection group
uh well the keys when we have uh so this
uh
or cardio is inside a disk so this uh
this or
a family of
dynamical systems is a one complex
parameter so it's the center of the disk
we choose the disk uh tangent to the
cardioid so let's look at the parameter
space and so we need to exclude uh the
half line from minus infinity to -1 12s
so we it's only because for this values
of the uh if you take the center there
so then you get two tangent points and
we want just one
then we Define uh the droplet as uh the
closed disk sent maximal close disk
centered at uh at this point P minus the
the uh this fixed cardioid and uh
and the interior of the droplet is
connected so it will be double so it
will have two components if uh uh
so in this piece in this region uh and
then we Define the set p uh this
calligraphic P if the tiles don't ramify
if the critical point Never Land on the
uh or on the on the droplet so it's the
same as saying that this singular set is
uh uh
uh so uh this is an illustration so we
take a different tangent cardioid in
this disk and then that's the uh the the
singular set and uh this time it's we
have disconnected sets so that's not in
our set p and this is the case when we
have two uh two tangent points and then
we disregard this situation because it's
in a different uh
space
and uh okay so forget about this and
then uh you look at the parameter space
so if the first para puzzle is when uh
is this uh exterior of this cardioid
because if we land outside of this so
then so we land on the after the first
step we uh
um
we get ramification of tiles so the
close-up picture is this and then uh if
we a ram if so
so that's a detail at 0.3 over 16. so
this is precisely this mandal bar set
and uh and so the guess is the following
I so I'm uh this is what we see from the
picture so some of this well for
polynomials like the case that we
describe described so this Basilica so
this is not difficult to prove but in
general so there are quite serious
difficulties and in but not uh so in
particular because this mandelba set is
much uh less understood it's not locally
connected but maybe I mean it's it's a
more difficult beast and uh well okay so
this is what we see and uh
say it's a guess so for any uh P for any
center of the of the disk in this circle
in the cardioid Dynamics so there exists
a c such that the corresponding Schwartz
reflection is a cross of the reflection
map in the uh in the modular group and
the polynomials with plus c
uh considering in the field in July
asset the welding is a factor of
question mark function as explained
earlier and this uh the correspondence
is byjection or maybe a homeomorphism
from the set P2 or one third of the so
you need to exclude the mean they'll do
it from the mandal bus head and take one
third of it so that's the picture of the
uh one third of the Mandela bar set
excluding the deltoid and this is uh
what you get by applying uh the question
mark function should be what you should
get by applying question mark function
to laminations Circle laminations
and that's that's it so thank you very
much
so I could not noticing the resemblance
between the first set you grew with the
original deltoid and the band with the
bare slice
yes right so and that's an excellent
question and I wanted to ask it myself
but then I decided I ran out of time
so let me show you nevertheless but
a case of my last slide
okay I need to look from beginning
ah
okay yeah
from current slice
okay so okay can somebody explain so
this is that the what you get Dil to it
that's the better slice of hexagonal uh
tourists they look identical
whoa
why is that okay so uh what we plan to
do we want to consider the Delta will
the disk inside the deltoid so in the in
that case uh you have a pentagons so you
get not only one group but a whole uh
so you get pentagons on the other hand
you get uh you get uh
um
polynomials so slice of polynomials
versus a slice of pentagons and uh then
there's an interesting uh
um
well the correspondences that arise
there okay I don't I cannot so I wanted
to find a model so that would give your
so in in this picture we we have just
one group so we don't have any space of
groups so uh but uh we we change
polynomials but uh you can go the other
way around so in the case of deltoids
you keep the same polynomial but you
change the oh sorry the case of
asteroids okay so that's the the better
okay so that's a mystery to me okay so
maybe I also show that if you look so
the the curves that appear in the series
of this uh hybrids of Julia sets limit
says they are not the only interesting
fractals here so if you look very
closely at the droplets so then and it's
the uh
gas model so that's the equilibrium
support of the equilibrium area if you
look closely then you see uh well random
curves like this so they are not as
pretty as the dynamical curves but some
people like them
so
that's probably
uh so that's uh the uh the level set of
the uh potential of the electric field
in Cologne gas models
okay so the ssle four
no I I I find uh uh it's amusing that in
the same uh
topic you get client groups July assets
and SLS all in one picture so
oh yes yes correct
uh uh no well
yes they're holder okay but not for four
not for four not four four
okay
sorry I run out of time so
more questions